I'll look who cold in the former Celtic
great he's the current broadcaster
analyst for the Celtics cornbread and
Maxwell cornbread Maxwell joining us hey
cornbread how are you hey Jolin how you
guys doing today
how is morale with the Celtics pretty
damn good you up three three oh I think
it's pretty good there's something seem
to be hitting on all cylinders you know
you still got guys right now who are out
obviously who won't play this year but
the guys who are here and talked to Brad
Stevens just a really happy right now
with the results and the way his team is
playing if I would have told you when
Kyrie went down that you guys got a
chance to go to the Eastern Conference
Finals what would you said well if you
told me Gordon Hayward went down in the
first five minutes of the season I'm
thinking that you're crazy so if you say
Kyrie going down I definitely say you
would doubly crazy it's just the fact
that everybody stepped up you know Terry
Rozier is going to another level right
now but shouldn't be surprised you know
the guys he's played against Isiah over
the last couple of years and then under
the tutelage of Kyrie Irving he stepped
up his game
Jason Tatum has been unbelievably good
and the south I think Brad Steve is
right now showing that he is possibly
the best coach right now in the NBA
these last minutes of these three games
we've seen a different coaching
philosophy and style you know what have
you seen from Brad Stevens with
certainly with these out of bounds plays
after a timeout I mean he's really
remarkable with that he obviously he's a
great coach I'm glad that the nation is
remembering that he's a great coach
going back to his butler days but you
know these are special moments here
Cedric yeah the coach said you know it
was really strange I think Celtic nation
for a while kind of held their breath
when Doc Rivers left going to going out
to Los Angeles and then all of a sudden
Danny Ainge goes out and and gets this
guy that none of us really knew about
but Danny had covered it for the longest
time so he understood and only ship
understood and you know Brasi
has come in and been an onion remark
he's been a remarkable coach I'm
wondering you know Ange was is he in the
Basketball Hall of Fame
well you know what look what his resume
is done he's won several championships
you know look what he's done as a G as a
general manager of this team getting
personnel and the Tracy's may it's gonna
be hard not to put Danny in there with
his complete resume if you think about
his total package as a player then it
was good but where his resume now
getting Kevin Garnett getting Kyrie
Irving you know having the suburbs
fathers kappa room and flexibility he's
done the unbelievable job so yeah there
there could be a nod there well he was a
great college player at BYU and then he
was a very good player I remember
watching
I remember watching age when he when he
was in college and and he was a he
averaged 24 game is a senior cornbread
say you know angel was good he was he
was good and a great athlete he played
well for the Celtics won some
championships there but I think if you
include what he's done as a GM you know
he's you might have the best coach in
the NBA and you might have the best GM
in the NBA well then he has done some
unbelievable moves you know the go ahead
and get Kyrie Irving to make a move here
look at the bigness one late the latest
one you think about Philadelphia
you have Soviets had the first pick in
the draft last year and they decide
they're going to give this big to
Philadelphia Philadelphia gives one it
market wanted folks they get him so be
to annotate them and they were able to
get paid them and that gave them an
opportunity to go out and get Gordon
Hayward but also in the process you get
Tatum but you also get a first round
draft choice which is which is the LA's
pick or Sacramento next year so solids
really are you know just have so much
flexibility so many good players so many
good things happening danny has been
that Danny's been that linchpin he
said cornbread Maxwell he's the radio
analyst for the Boston Celtics
if the Celtics match up against LeBron
how is this you know that they have
depth here you have a variety of guys
maybe you don't have that one star but
it seems to be working for them so how
does this change things or make Boston
even tougher with Cleveland well I think
one thing that you do have a home court
so you do start the series out of their
home
hopefully the Celtics were if they were
if they're able to get by a philadelphia
year I think that you look at LeBron
Jameses he's that guy right now he's
morphed into it that's something else I
thought that there was greatness but but
what's the word after greatness because
of Ron James seem to have gone there I
have never seen a guy at 32 years old
lead the league in minutes played and
still has a have a reservoir of energy
to play in the playoffs the way he has
so he's been remarkable at his best
which is probably this year
how does LeBron compare to bird the one
year the best year of his career the
bronze best year I think it would maybe
top everybody's best year even Michael
Jordan's best year real yeah because I
just looked away plays he has more
rebounds he has more assists he has no
more blocked shots you know you can talk
about yours all you want to but LeBron
James reminds me more of a better Magic
Johnson
being able to put the ball on the floor
defending the way he does scoring the
basketball
remember the three-point shot even it's
you know I know Dan you you were big
Larry Bird man you like that me told me
from time to time but the three-point
shot really wasn't really info during
Larry Bird's first championship when he
when we played against Houston during
that series the last game in Houston six
games only five three-pointers were
tested for the whole game so the game
has just changed so much that you think
how guys play it how they perform
and even you think as great as Jordan
was we might have to change his game
right now to fit into what they do in
the NBA Jordan yeah he'd probably be a
right-handed version of Harden not it
not as good as 3-point shooter but that
ability to you know take contact but he
could also beat you to the hoop and he
can also shoot a jumper but you know I
know when we start to mix generations
that's where it gets a little dicey
there
I just think Byrd at his best when he
was maybe 30 when he almost averaged a
triple-double probably was better than
LeBrons best year but LeBron is a better
player and you think you think LeBron is
better than Magic Johnson yeah looking
at here's the thing I don't want to kick
in my era because I had a great year
that I played there no you know magic
and bird in Jordan and all these
different guys I played against but you
know you have to give it give it this
dude
the greatest players of mean of all the
times that nobody talks about is the
chemo Elijah one and that's the first
guy pick and the reason I pick it
wouldn't tell you right off because what
he did he control both into the floor
Jordan controlled the office being the
floor but but if you look at the came a
chemical controlled the offensive end
and the defensive end my last year in
the league I played with Elijah Juan and
I think a game we played against Seattle
he had 46 25 eight and eight that's how
great the clarity woods and and I think
that's how dominant he was but people
seem to forget that and they talk about
all these great players but even now
when you look at players Kobe Bryant
went back to train with Olajuwon LeBron
James went back during the offseason to
train with Elijah Hwan so that just
shows you really his greatness on both
ends of the floor
yeah I'm right there with you with a cam
he's my favorite big man of all time and
I think that he's he's underrated I
really do I think he was magically a
great footwork and you know thank God he
got a couple of titles there you know
well well Joe Jordan bead right now
that's what Jolin be said who
watch yeah you know over the years
that's the guy he really got his game
pattern after you know was Hakeem
Olajuwon you know not only was it came a
great basketball player but he was a
hockey goalie goalie and that to me is
one of those things we think about the
gasps weren't working when he's a bird
is a pleather system that's how great he
was he was he was a bot he could pick up
what you would do and do it better than
you the next day that's how great he was
McHale gave us a couple of bird trash
talk stories do you have one for us
before we say good but like a sneaky one
I haven't heard cuz McHale was pretty
good with his bird trash talk stories
well you know only trash talk I think
about Larry Bird is the first time I
ever saw him play and the first day he
walked into camp and I was that year I
had averaged 19 points a game or we get
Larry Bird and I'm sitting over there on
the big stage and Larry walks in and I
give the slow clap I'm going okay here
he comes
great white hope here we go here we go
so we get on the course and now I have
to guard bird I'm guarding from about 10
feet away hands down
swish I say okay maybe I was lucky shot
closer I got the more he saw the drain
shots I remember leaving practice that
day walking to the nearest black person
I could find and going you know what
that down white guys can play so that
would be my not the trash talk he did
what was the trash talking idea and how
he shipped my mouth as a clear as black
players we have this this arrogance that
we were so much better than white
players I happen to play with the
greatest to fight players of all time
put together on one team McHale and bird
so I think that was God's Way of shore
my ignorance this is what I'm going to
show you right now Martin Luther King my
foot said we're good to talk to you have
fun tonight always good to visit with
you all right
that's cornbread Maxwell for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show at
you
[Music]